CAN I SHARE IT?
WHILE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS SENATOR GILLIBRAND
DROPPED OUT OF THE 2020
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY ON TWITTER.
SHE WASN'T GOING TOIC -- TO MAKE
THE DEBATE.
SHE WOULD BE HOPE TO SOMEBODY'S
VICE-PRESIDENT.
>> SO WOULD I BY THE WAY.
>> THAT'S GOOD TO KNOW.
>> MARIANNE WILLIAMSON!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> MARIANNE WILLIAMSON WON'T
MAKE THE DEBATE EITHER.
>> I TALKED TO HER TODAY ABOUT
IT.
I THINK SHE HAS A STRATEGY.
BREAKING NEWS LATER.
SHE HAS A PLAN!
>> MAYBE THE OCTOBER DEBATES.
>> ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT HER
DECIDING TO DROP OUT?
>> IT'S A REALISTIC VIEWPOINT.
DIDN'T CAUGHT ON AND NEVER HAD A
MESSAGE THAT RESONATE.
I THINK IT'S BETTER FOR HER AND
NEW YORK FOR HER.
>> NO, HE TALKING ABOUT
GILLIBRAND.
>> PEOPLE IN NEW YORK WERE
SAYING, EXCUSE ME.
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T BECOME
PRESIDENT.
FOCUS ON BEING HERE AT HOME.
>> TRIMMING THE FAT IS GOOD.
OTHERS SHOULD TAKE NOTE.
AND THE CNN CLIMATE CHANGE
THING.
>> IS THAT A COMMENT ABOUT HER
WEIGHT?
>> HOW DARE YOU.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> YOU HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO DEAL
WITH IT.
>> YOU INVENTED A WORD.
>> THE NEW DANA.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> AN AMAZING PACKAGE ON
HOMELESSNESS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO COVER THAT
HERE.